This April, 19 million new cars were sold
in America — the highest level since 2005.
But these weren’t just any old cars.
Today’s Chevy Silverados and Ram 1500s are
not quite the same as those sold a year or
even a few months ago.
Something very strange is happening across
the industry.
Features, packages, even certain parts have
suddenly disappeared from recently manufactured
vehicles.
An exceptionally observant buyer of a ‘21
Silverado, for example, might notice their
truck getting about one less mile per gallon
than was advertised earlier this year on the
same model.
Recent Peugeot 308 hatchback owners, meanwhile,
may be surprised to find the digital speedometer
shown on TV replaced with an old-fashioned
analog version.
And the dashboard display on the Renault Arkana
mysteriously got a little bit smaller.
It’s as if they’re playing a game: What
tiny things can they change without anyone
noticing?
The actual explanation is a global shortage
of semiconductors — the chips that power
virtually every electronic device, from rice
cookers to Xboxes.
Earlier this year, auto manufacturers found
themselves in an awkward position — the
average car is made up of about 30,000 individual
parts, yet they were missing one — worth
perhaps only 4 or $5, one-hundredth of a percent
of the final selling price.
It didn’t matter.
Without one, single component, everything
had to wait.
At first, factories simply stopped producing
and workers went home.
Ford, Honda, Volkswagen, Audi, and GM all
shut down at least a few of their production
lines.
Audi furloughed 10,000 workers, and Volkswagen
predicts it will sell 100,000 fewer cars as
a direct result.
The total damage to the industry could be
upwards of $60 billion, despite ordinarily
spending only about 5% of its GDP on semiconductors.
Eventually, though, many brands resigned to
cutting back features, realizing the problem
is here to stay.
It’s not just cars.
Sony doesn’t expect to meet demand for its
PS5 until next year, Nintendo can’t make
enough Switches, and even deep-pocketed Apple,
usually immune to such disruptions, has been
affected.
According to Goldman Sachs, semiconductors
touch 169 different industries, and the worst-case
scenario would be a 1% reduction in U.S. GDP.
Given how strong the incentives are to alleviate
the shortage, what on earth could cause such
a costly disaster?
Sponsored by Hover.
Get 10% off the domain you need to turn your
side project, personal brand, or startup into
a reality.
Early last year, demand for cars around the
world plummeted.
At the same time, sales of home electronics
skyrocketed — routers, monitors, webcams,
keyboards, iPads, and so on.
Car companies canceled their semiconductor
orders, consumer electronics brands ordered
extra, and to the extent the two overlap,
production lines shifted to producing for
the latter.
Automobile sales, however, jumped back much
faster than expected — almost as fast as
they had fallen in March.
Already by September of last year, demand
for cars was near normal, 2019 levels.
Not used to such wild swings in demand, when
Americans got back to their usual habit of
buying trucks the size of small European countries,
car manufacturers rushed to order more parts.
The problem is that ‘semiconductor’ and
‘rushed’ are practically antonyms.
There’s nothing fast about producing billions
of transistors on a single chip or maintaining
conditions 100,000 times more sterile than
a hospital operating room.
When you hear semiconductors have extraordinarily
long lead times, think not days or even weeks
but rather months.
Many, many months.
A single chip takes no fewer than fourteen
and as many as 20 weeks just to manufacture.
After that, you can expect an additional 6
weeks for assembly, testing, and packaging.
This, mind you, assumes the requisite machines
are sitting around, ready to start the moment
an order is received, and doesn’t include
delivery time.
Ignoring these two giant caveats, each chip
will take three to six and a half months from
start to finish — longer than the entire
dip in car sales last year.
But if it were that simple, supply would’ve
caught up with demand months ago.
Instead, some analysts don't expect the current
shortage to end until later this year, or,
even next year.
Something else is happening here.
The semiconductor supply chain isn’t just
slow.
It also involves many different parties.
Steps which would be separated only by conveyor
belts or departments in other industries are
so complex for semiconductors as to justify
entirely different, highly specialized companies.
And, while efficient, specialization can also
cause problems.
Imagine, for instance, last September when
Toyota saw its cars start to fly off the lot
— it would’ve immediately adjusted its
sales forecast accordingly.
If sales the previous month were 18 million,
it would’ve extrapolated a trendline and
added some cushion — ordering, let’s say,
20 million.
But remember, Toyota’s order doesn’t just
go directly to a factory.
Instead, it might go to a company like Panasonic,
which might be responsible for delivering
the car’s navigation unit.
Panasonic, on the other hand, will see an
order of 20 million units, extrapolate, and
add some cushion — maybe ordering 21 million.
It, likewise, may order from another intermediary,
who, again, will extrapolate and add slack.
By the time an actual manufacturer, or “fab”,
receives an order, it may bear little resemblance
to the original.
Each step of the process involves an independent,
profit-maximizing firm, making the most logical
decision given its limited information.
In aggregate, however, demand gets more and
more distorted.
Under normal conditions, this effect is known
and manageable.
But when orders come flooding in all at once,
as they did in September, manufacturers are
very easily overwhelmed.
And because demand shot up everywhere at once,
every company was effectively competing for
the same, limited supply.
Each one, trying both to minimize the risk
of under-ordering and maximize its priority
in line, inflated its order.
For manufacturers, the difficulty is not so
much solving the shortage — with lead time
so long, there’s really nothing that can
be done except build more factories, which
takes years.
Their real task is to project confidence.
If they can credibly convince buyers of their
capacity, buyers stop inflating orders, and
at least some of the shortage will naturally
resolve.
It’s fundamentally no different from toilet
paper, masks, or diapers.
If even one person fears a shortage, they’ll
start hoarding supplies, forcing everyone,
including the most rational, to play along.
Shipping prices are at recent highs, and Chinese
companies may be hoarding supplies for fear
of U.S. sanctions, but no one truly knows
how much is simply panic buying.
In reality, the “shortage” may not be
much of a shortage at all.
What if there was a shortage, though?
Supply may not be severely constrained now,
but if this is what merely believing it to
be, looks like, what would it, actually?
The very nature of semiconductors all but
guaranteed the dominance of a small number
of companies.
Opening a new factory easily costs upwards
of $10 billion, and as much as twice that
for the most cutting-edge.
But because of how fast the underlying technology
changes, it will very likely only remain useful
for 5 or so years.
That means burning through a million dollars
every five hours.
There’s absolutely no room for mistakes
or downtime.
Factories run 24/7, 365 days a year, with
no exceptions.
With capital costs this high, it’s simply
not possible for new companies to dip their
toes in the market.
Over time, the number of competitors has dwindled,
from 25 in 2002 to just three by 2016.
The winner in each major chip technology revolution
reinvests its earnings back, ensuring they
dominate even harder in the next.
With just a handful of competitors, the industry
is among the most consolidated in the world
— more so than airlines, biotechnology,
or soft drinks.
While not, strictly speaking, a monopoly,
Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing Company
is the clear winner in the contract foundry
market — which produce on demand for companies
like Apple and Toyota.
That’s a lot of very important eggs in one
basket.
Especially given that over 90% of TSMC fabs
are located in one, politically fraught country:
Taiwan.
When semiconductors are flowing, no one pays
much attention to just how amazing their existence
is.
But when they stop, when a single ship blocks
the Suez Canal, or when an oil pipeline is
held for ransom, the fragility of our modern
world quickly becomes apparent.
And yet, it’s in part that very fragility
which makes it, in all but the weirdest of
times, so dependable.
TSMC needs Taiwan, Taiwan needs TSMC, and
at least for now, the world needs TSMC.
What you and I need, on the other hand, is
an online presence that we control.
One of the first things I did when I started
this channel was create a website.
And to do that, you first need to reserve
a domain name — a .com or .io or .app — which
you can do with Hover for, in some cases,
as low as $2.99.
A website is the only place on the internet
that you really, truly own.
On Twitter or YouTube, we’re just users
at the whim of algorithms.
Even if you don’t need a website, Hover
can also help you set up your very own email
address — your name @ whatever you want
.com, for example.
Hover is upfront, reliable, and affordable,
with only the best customer support.
Reserve your domain with Hover and make your
idea come to life with 10% off using the link
in the description.